[Music]
[Music]
good morning unfortunately I'm not Vicki
vice-captain
Oh Vicki Vicki has was unable to come
he's recovering from from a medical
problem I have to let me assure you he's
he's fine I've talked to him this
morning he's getting better and he'll be
back soon but he simply was unable to
make it today
I'm Francis Lowe and I was asked to
chair instead of him so let me welcome
you to this morning's session of the
worlds of Philip Morrison in which we
honor and entertain and are entertained
by our friend and colleague Philip
Morrison Vicki ten years ago wrote a
piece for Technology Review which I
think one should call an appreciation
and he was planning to read it and it
seemed to me the best thing for me to do
was always to read it to you so here is
Vice cops on Morrison Technology Review
98 1976 how it's changed the last word
Phil Morrison is more than a person he
represents an attitude a way of life a
symbol for what I would like to call joy
of insight or lust for knowledge nobody
else has better demonstrated or rather
embodied what it means to the human soul
to perceive or recognize a new
scientific discovery or a new
theoretical insight
I used the word soul advisedly because
Phil's character contains so much of it
scientific knowledge and understanding
is not a purely cerebral affair it is
soaked with emotion excitement and
nervous tension as everybody knows who
has heard Phil talk the life of a
scientist would not be worthwhile were
it not for those few moments maybe two
or three per year when he feels an
exhilarating joy deep in his guts of
having understood something having seen
new connections
bring things together now I know what it
means these moments of joy occur from
time to time no matter whether it has
one's own or someone else's discovery in
my life more often than not such a
moment happened during a talk or a
conversation with Phil I remember an
unforgettable talk at a Harvard evening
seminar more than 30 years ago when he
told us about Watson and Crick's double
helix just a few weeks after they
discovered it it was the physicist
Morrison who immediately recognized the
immense significance of the discovery
and he gave us a broad picture in his
inimitable way of how this development
will revolutionize biology we went away
from it with pride to be alive at a time
of such revelations Phil's strength is
the broad brush painting of the
scientific landscape you get the great
connections the deep relations and the
far perspectives surely here and there
some detail gets lost some conclusions
are not quite tight but these are a
small price to pay for great panorama
and the grand Vista which we get in
exchange many people have asked how Phil
can manage all this when does he read
all the books and journals
when does he acquire his phenomenal
knowledge of what happens in all
branches of natural science on top of
all this he has been book editor as a
scientific American for the last 15
years where he reviews four to six books
every month and must have read 10 times
as many he possesses a phenomenal gift
of the quick and thorough grasp have you
ever seen him read a book by turning a
page every one or two seconds
he knows the content and what's more he
knows the significance and relevance of
it this fact has been experimentally
tested
I envy this in him more than anything
else every student at MIT knows Phil's
classic art of lecturing or should I say
romantic I should you can count on
getting a new and unconventional view of
the subject surely we must listen
carefully because the ideas come fast
with Phil there are moments when his
throat muscles have a hard time to
follow the speed of his thoughts but
these are the moments when the lecture
hall is filled to the brim with the
intensity of his thoughts and the
tension of his enthusiasm if you need a
proof that true science is not a dry and
impersonal subject go and listen to Phil
he has worked in many fields of physics
and he is the best counter example to
the narrow specialists of today no
wonder his latest field of endeavor is
that part of science with the widest and
grandest scope
astronomy but there is more to his human
approach to life than his broad
understanding of science science is the
relation of man to nature but Phil's
interest goes far beyond pure science
the predicament predicament of man the
social and political problems education
and healthcare have always been among
his most important concerns everything
human fascinates him be it great
ordinary are ominous we never help is
needed whenever there is a cause to do
some good go to Phil he will be ready
and full of youthful enthusiasm is he
really 70 now
our speakers this morning scarcely need
an introduction nevertheless it's my job
to introduce them and so I will say a
few words about each of them our first
is Professor Carl Sagan who is the David
Duncan professor of astronomy and space
sciences and director of the laboratory
for planetary studies at Cornell
University
he has played a leading role in the
Mariner Viking and Voyager expeditions
to the planets for which he receives a
NASA medal for exceptional scientific
achievement his scientific research has
enhanced an inter alter our
understanding of the greenhouse effect
on Venus dust storms on Mars the organic
haze untighten the origin of life and
the search for life elsewhere both of
our speakers this morning also have had
several careers and the second career of
Professor Sagan is author
he is the author co-author or editor of
more than 20 books including Broca's
brain Comet contact and the dragons of
Eden for which he was awarded the
Pulitzer Prize his Emmy and Peabody
award-winning television series cosmos
became the most widely watched series in
the history of American Public
Television I would there are very few
scientists who have tried have been able
to do this to reach the public with with
serious discussion of science and what
is going on in our in our fields or who
have even tried to do it and I think
that professor Sagan deserves great
credit for having brought some
understanding of science to the general
public in recent years dr. Sagan and his
colleagues have been engaged in research
on the long-term consequences of nuclear
war and covering the phenomenon of
nuclear winter of which you all know
about it but this work he was given the
annual awards for public service of the
Federation of American scientists and of
physicians for social responsibility as
well as the Leo Szilard award for
physics in the public interest of
American Physical Society it's a
pleasure to welcome professor Sagan here
to MIT to Phil's celebration his talk
today is titled joining the universe
Thank You dr. Loe I'm delighted to be
here to be able to add my voice to the
voice of I think it's fair to say that
the world scientific community in
celebrating Philip Morrison I want to
discuss a fairly broad number of topics
all of which one way or another are
connected with Philip Morrison's
manifold interest and I'd like to begin
with a perspective which I I think still
is the one of the inheritors today of
this long tradition and the tradition
could shortly be called the Copernican
perspective but it's much broader than
that in human affairs there's a kind of
aristocratic habit of thought that crops
up in most recent human societies the
idea that because of some accident of
birth some people have an otherwise
unmerited central position in the social
universe from plantagenet princelings to
the children of robber barons and
Central Committee members this
self-serving attitude seems as natural
as breathing for those who are born into
privilege or power and it's connected
with sexism racism nationalism and other
deadly chauvinism that continue to
plague the human species uncommon
strength of character is needed to
resist the blandishments of those who
assure us of some supposed superiority
over our fellows since scientists are
people it should not surprise us the
comparable doctrines have entered from
time to
the scientific worldview until the
sixteenth century for example almost all
scientists considered it absolutely
evident from observation that the earth
was at the center of the universe and
that the Sun and the moon and the
planets revolved around us and while
there were good reasons on the basis of
conformation between theory and
experiment for such a view nevertheless
some of its popularity I think must be
due to a kind of emotional resonance the
universe was structured around us
created for our benefit we were at the
center everything else goes around us
it's difficult to contemplate such a
model without feeling some small
stirring of pride the entire universe
created for us we must really be
something and this doctrine supported by
sort of common sense observations
consistent with church dogma taught in
the schools it survived in Europe for at
least two centuries after the time of
Copernicus before it was supplanted by
the more uncomfortable idea that the
earth went around the Sun wasn't at the
center it was just one of many planets
and the appeal of this geocentric
doctrine I think can still be felt in
the continuing worldwide popularity of
the entirely spurious doctrine of
astrology well every other such proposal
to remove the human species from cosmic
center stage has been resisted sometimes
violently for reasons that are
emotionally rather similar so consider
this list of propositions that the stars
are other Suns that the stars are made
of the same kind of stuff that we have
down here that the earth is much older
than the human species that the Sun is
in some obscure exterior spiral arm of a
vast Milky Way galaxy
that the spiral nebulae are other
galaxies that the position or velocity
or acceleration of the earth in space
does not give us some privileged
reference frame that human beings like
all the other plants and animals on
earth have evolved from other and more
ancient species well every one of these
propositions has elicited a reasonably
fierce scientific debate in every case I
think the Fuhrer of the debate has
something more to it than just
scientific debate it has to do with our
fear of losing our imagined importance
in the cosmos the cosmic center stage
but still despite the powerful social
forces arrayed against them every one of
these hypotheses has been convincingly
of verifying the sequence of deep
provincial ization that they represent
constitute some of the key scientific
advances since the Renaissance these
debates have been decisively settled in
favour of a proposition that can be
summed up in a single sentence
we are nothing special this set of blows
to the anthropocentric worldview has
been more than a little disappointing to
human chauvinists and it's hard to be
human without feeling some sense of
chauvinism but it seems to me that the
gains of our new perspective far
outweigh the losses we find ourselves
maybe trembling just a little on the
threshold of a vast and awesome universe
rich in mystery and promise that utterly
Dwarfs in time and space and in
potential the tidy and propo centric
world of our ancestors we have sent
dozens of robot emissaries to the nearby
planets and for spacecraft to the Stars
we have launched telescopes into Earth
orbit the peer billions of light-years
into the depth
of space and now we are on the verge of
initiating an observational test of the
most recent self-congratulatory
chauvinism the contention that in all
this great universe of a hundred billion
galaxies and a billion trillion stars
there is no species so wise so
intelligent so advanced as we this topic
is called the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence or SETI
for short and it began in a famous 1959
paper in the journal Nature written by
Philip Morrison and Giuseppi cocconi
these days the revolutionary nature of
this paper is sometimes forgotten the
prevailing attitudes in 1959 were that
the search for life elsewhere was
somewhere between science fiction and
hokum it had suffered serious losses in
credibility going back to Percival
Lowell who taught at this institution
who believed that Mars was covered by a
network of canals built by intelligent
beings all of which turned out to be
entirely spurious what Morrison and
Coney did was to ask the question what
is the most effective means of
interstellar communication by another
advanced civilization to us they
concluded that the radio spectrum was by
far the most convenient the most noise
free
the quickest compared to alternative non
electromagnetic means and more than that
they proposed that in the vast microwave
spectrum vast radio spectrum there were
a few specific frequencies which might
be the preferential frequencies for such
communication of because of laws of
physics sharing between the transmitting
and receiving civilizations and they
explicitly pointed to the 1420 megahertz
line of neutral monatomic hydrogen and
this is now called one of the so-called
magic frequencies that is frequencies
which are imagined to be shared by a
common knowledge of the laws of nature
and the nature of the galaxy between a
hypothetical transmitting civilization
and our own from that time to this film
arson has played a central role in the
development and monotonically increasing
respectability of the subject right now
there is a search program going on at
Harvard Massachusetts led by Paul
Horowitz of Harvard in which 8.4 million
separate channels each much narrower
than Hertz are being examined
simultaneously as the telescope scans
the skies
visible from Harvard Massachusetts and a
still much more sophisticated program is
is being worked on by the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration in
both of these efforts
phil has played a central role sharing
NASA committees and providing
inspiration and insight and motivation
we of course don't know how these
searches will turn out
there are many aspects of it that are
strange and many of the descriptions of
the subjects have metaphors and insights
which go straight back to Philip Morris
and many of those who speak them may not
even know where they came from for
example the they know very common
comment that one here is that and that I
myself have used that you must expect
monologue not dialogue because of the
great distances but that is not as big a
deficit as you might imagine that
Socrates speaks to us even if we do not
speak to Socrates we treasure certain
kinds of one-way communication that
insight in metaphor goes straight back
to film how this search will wind up
knowing of course noticed it may turn
out that there will be a comprehensive
very narrow band search of both the
northern and southern skies or a period
of decades if on the other hand we would
receive a signal of intelligent origin
even before it was decrypted we would
have learned something of the very
greatest importance that there are other
beings out there that they are almost
certainly more advanced than we because
the statistical chance of them being
within this very brief few decade long
period after the invention of radio
astronomy has very low probability and
therefore that they have avoided
self-destruction the fact that that is
possible is knowledge well worth having
and of course a successful detection and
decryption would in ways that we can
imagine but cannot accurately foresee
change the history of the human species
if that were ever to happen there is no
question that we would all owe the
greatest debt of gratitude to Pho
Morrison I don't want you to think that
this openness to to speculative ideas
is is untempered in Phil Morrison's
personality there is also a very
appropriate dose of scientific
skepticism which you can see in many
different areas
his famous remarket I will believe a
black hole when I see one is an example
and it is exactly the tension between
this openness and the skepticism which I
think is is one of Phil's great virtues
one well worth emulating if we can so
let's let's think of Phil as pioneering
this the subject of the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence at the
same time in the sixties that there was
a kind of worldwide epidemic of people
who believed we were at that same moment
being visited by what we called
unidentified flying objects this was had
captivated many and not just the the
purchases of weekly newspapers sold in
supermarkets I can remember James
McDonald a respected atmospheric
physicist remember the National Academy
of Sciences who believed that there were
some anecdotal cases which were so
compelling us to make us really
reconsider the possibility that we were
being visited and I arranged for
McDonald to present to fill his
McDonald's best cases and somehow while
being extremely kind and generous the
the balloon was punctured in a period of
about 15-20 minutes extremely friendly
conversation and Phil there did I think
for for many of us a a great service at
the same time Phil was replete with
anecdotes of an enlightening nature one
of which I will retell but from memory
and so if I get some details wrong
please forgive me Phil
the story goes like this a New Mexico
Highway patrolman
is driving along a road that he had many
times before driven along and suddenly
before his eyes he sees a great metallic
saucer-shaped object land in somebody's
farm and it's it's right there on the
ground he sees it he happens to know
some scientists at Los Alamos calls them
up explains what happened right there at
the highway and they say keep your eye
on it and we'll be there as soon as we
can and so let's imagine the Sun rising
in the sky the highway patrolman sitting
there in his and his patrol car and the
saucer shaped object sitting there in
the field
the scientists arrive the day and the
highway patrolman then approached this
object the farmer is there on the farm
and he seems totally oblivious of this
strange object could it be that it was
invisible to the farmer but visible to
the scientists and the highway patrolman
they approached the farm and say could
you tell us a little about that UFO that
just landed farmer turns around looks
straight at it and says what UFO well
they talk a little bit and it turns out
that that what had been thought was a
UFO was just a kind of lenticular
metallic storage structure that had been
there for years and there was only one
problem in the in the highway patrolman
'he's argument he miss took his glimpse
to mean the thing had landed and never
seen it before
phil's lesson was that in a scheme of
inferential argument you need only break
one link in the scheme for the argument
to collapse
I also remember it was a time when
something called the Bermuda Triangle
was imagined to be eating ships and
airplanes and Phil raised the question
of why aren't trains being eaten
ships in the ocean airplanes flying over
the ocean there is a a first-order
hypothesis about what happens to make
them disappear they sink trains on the
other hand do not have that option and
therefore here we have the possibility
of normalizing the hypothesis and and
then as soon as that point sank in Phil
then would come up with a story about a
train that did disappear well maybe it
wasn't exactly a train the story as I
remember it goes like this a a large
rotor for some rotary machinery was
being shipped by train on a railroad
flat car in a vertical position with
guy-wires
supporting it it left the manufacturing
plant the train arrived at whatever the
transshipment depot and supposed to be
taken off and the flat car was there but
no rotor much too large to have been
hijacked and they went over every mile
of the track had mysteriously
disappeared and this problem was
unsolved for forgotten long period of
time decades until in dreaming a swamp a
few miles from the railroad track they
found the rotor it had obviously broken
its guy-wires and don't know how tall
the thing was ten meters or something
had had rolled a few miles down to the
to the swamp can you imagine what it
must have been like if anyone had simply
been wandering by
one of Phil's most remarkable
characteristics is his his ability as a
teacher I come from Cornell University
and a long time since phil was on the
faculty there but his influence is still
palpable people who attend his lectures
never forget them he's had a powerful
influence on course curricula for
children in films and television
programs yeah
I'm sure many of you have saw seen the
remarkable film that he and Phyllis
Morrison and the Eames teams as did
called powers of 10
Philip Daly who is a is responsible for
the remarkable set of science films in
the BBC over the last few decades stop
by just before I came up to ask me to
mention that phil has been a major
source of inspiration for the BBC and
even attempting to do science films and
I can certainly say that for the project
I've been involved with in television
science education phil has also been a
leading source of inspiration his
articles in Scientific American book
reviews were mentioned by Francis Lowe I
think it's fair to say that many people
learn more from the reviews and then
firm actually reading the books
there is a kind of condensation down to
the essence of the thing which is hard
to extract oneself in reading the book
and I think these reviews are also
marked by a generosity of spirit
and which insights are attributed to the
authors which they often never had is
just filler
Phil in teaching science to the public
constantly stress is not only what we
know but how it is we came to know it he
constantly stresses respect for the work
of the hands as well as the mind
following that ancient tradition of the
Ionian scientists who a certain sense
can be said to have founded the
scientific tradition of the West Phil
exemplifies the responsibility that I I
personally believe scientists have to
communicate science to the public there
are many reasons why why it's important
one is just that we love our subject we
are enthusiastic about it it's very
natural to try to communicate what you
love to others it's one of those
nonzero-sum games like like love itself
and which every time you give you gain
in addition there are clear sort of
naked scientific self-interest reasons
if we wish the public coffers to support
science we have a clear responsibility
to explain what the virtues of science
are I think we are a scientific species
it's the one of the very few things we
do uniquely that other animals do not do
I think every person on the planet is on
some level a scientist but unfortunately
school curricula and the social
conventions work not to encourage but to
discourage this sort of interest and as
scientists I think we have a
responsibility to counter that and then
there is the clear social responsibility
that we live in a time civilization
culture deeply involved with dependent
upon science and technology and the
clearest prescription for disaster is
for the public
not to know about science and technology
how can the public manage their own
future if they don't know some of the
essential tools for doing that
management so I don't know what mix of
these reasons has involved the Philip
Morrison in a science education for the
broad public but there are many of us
grateful that he has done so on the
issue of the mix of openness and
skepticism I want also to mention Phil's
courageous and very long-standing
opposition to the continuation of the
mad nuclear arms race phil was involved
with Manhattan Project he armed the
Nagasaki bomb it was as deeply involved
as anyone in the development of nuclear
weapons to bring an end to world war two
and to beat the Nazis to this weapon of
great destructive power on the other
hand soon after the end of the war it
became clear to many scientists
including Phil that there were grave
dangers of continuing in this direction
he has spoken out often and courageously
on this issue I can remember being at a
dinner at the Pentagon in a previous
administration in which a Secretary of
Defense much more moderate than the one
that no in office was vehemently
decrying a study that Phil and a group
of people I think called the Boston
study group and put together on why it
was in the national interest to make
massive cuts in the Department of
Defense budget
the contention being that it would
strengthen the national security of the
United States if you did it in a
prescribed way as you might imagine that
did not
to fall on on receptive ears at the
Department of Defense it was ahead of
its time I think that time is coming
there is there are many issues related
to the cessation or at least slowing
down of the nuclear arms race I just
want to mention one and that's the issue
of continued testing of nuclear weapons
in the 1963 limited test ban treaty
there is in the preamble a moving phrase
about how the United States and the
Soviet Union pledged their efforts to
ending the arms race and moving towards
a ban on the testing of all nuclear
weapons that was 1963 in the 23 years
since then there has not been much
progress in 1963 there was a remarkable
moment in recent history the United
States and the Soviet Union with the the
Cuban Missile Crisis had managed to
scare each other almost to death I had
for very good reason Bobby Kennedy wrote
that he thought that there was a 50/50
chance of a central nuclear exchange
between the United States and the Soviet
Union over that incident for a moment
the leaders of the two countries had
focused their attention on the nuclear
arms race and in a speech at American
University the American president John F
Kennedy announced a unilateral u.s.
moratorium on the further testing of
nuclear weapons the next day the full
text of that speech was published
remarkably enough in his vest 'ya and in
Pravda within the week the Soviet
premier Nikita Khrushchev announced a
unilateral Soviet moratorium on further
above-ground testing of new
and which was merely coincidentally
happening in the same week as the
American moratorium but what we had was
a de facto ban on further above-ground
nuclear testing by the two principle
nuclear powers what then happened is a
remarkable moment in recent history in
which the two countries vied with each
other to be nice the the Soviets removed
their objection to the stationing of
neutral observers in Yemen the Americans
removed their objections to the
credentials of the Hun proposed
Hungarian delegation to the United
Nations there was a mutual Duffing of
the hats before things got out of hand
however an American academic named bar
Goran was arrested in Moscow on grounds
of espionage and the climate heated up
and there was a a real danger of the
test ban treaty unraveling but mr.
Kennedy made private remonstrances with
mr. Khrushchev and Khrushchev then
released in the American academic saying
that while he he Khrushchev was not
convinced that he was innocent of
espionage charges because the American
president wished it so strongly he
Khrushchev as a gesture of humanitarian
dedication released him and then the it
was time to convert the de facto treaty
to a de jure treaty Averill Harriman was
sent to Moscow as ambassador got off the
airplane a reporter from toss said to
him something like mr. ambassador
considering the grave tensions between
the two countries and and the
difficulties of such a treaty how long
do you think it will be
before a successful treaty whom he
negotiated Herriman said if mr.
Khrushchev wishes such a treaty half as
much as mr. Kennedy I'll be back on this
airplane in two weeks 13 days later the
1963 test ban treaty was signed and from
that date of this no American or Soviet
nuclear weapon has been tested on the
ground in the air or in space on August
6th of 1985 on the 40th anniversary of
the Hiroshima bomb the Soviet Union
announced a unilateral moratorium on
further underground testing the American
response has been to explode 20
underground nuclear weapons and to
contemptuously reject the Soviet offer
this is an opportunity which may not
recur it is very clear that the longer
the Soviets continued their moratorium
the greater will be the pressure on the
Soviet leadership from the nuclear arms
establishment in the Soviet Union and it
may be that the two nations will
perpetually remain out of phase what it
seems to me is our objective is to
arrange things so that they are in phase
long enough in reasonableness to to make
a significant decline in this mad race
to oblivion an American private group
the National Resources Defense Council
has established a seismic monitoring
station in the Soviet test area near
Semipalatinsk so now know that argument
has been swept away and we hear other
sorts of arguments to give an idea of
the desperation of the justification
here are three ways that have been
proposed by this administration that the
Soviets can cheat one they can wait for
a natural earthquake in Central Asia
and test their weapons then even there
by the way the seismic signatures of
natural earthquakes and nuclear weapons
are different too
they could make they could decouple they
could make a vast underground cavity and
muffle the sound of the explosion but
yeah I guess not is the right word but
for any weapon of significant yield you
have to excavate such an enormous volume
of earth that it should be readily
detectable by satellite reconnaissance
and then the the pride of place in these
arguments is the third argument due to
Edward Teller which is this the Soviets
will cheat by exploding nuclear weapons
on the far side of the Sun
stopping testing is a is a long lever
arm to ceasing the nuclear arms race and
to bring us into a regime in which we
can set about the urgent task of making
major verifiable and bilateral cuts in
this absurd joint arsenal of almost
60,000 weapons of mass destruction and
if we succeed in doing that some measure
of inspiration will have come again from
Philip Morris now I want to mention just
one more topic before I sum up and that
has to do with exploration Phil is an
explorer and Explorer in many senses but
also an explorer in the traditional
sense going out to new lands
he has traveled widely but kind of
exploration I'm talking about is real
old-time exploration with explorers Phil
is on the advisory board of the
Planetary Society a hundred thousand
member worldwide organization that is
doted to the exploration of the solar
system as well as the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and I just
like to to give you a vision of
something that is possible it is a joint
us-soviet land and woman'd
mission to Mars there's not any
appropriate word to say man and woman
that man certainly seems wrong because
it I mean there are women astronauts
these out half the species and some of
the alternatives like
food missions
lends itself to misunderstanding
a Mars is a world of wonders the
scientific justification for going there
it's very clear for one thing a billion
years ago there was liquid water all
over the planet rivers were gushing
there were lakes is even a contention
that there were oceans on Mars a billion
years ago something very important
happened between then and now in terms
of massive climatic change and it might
even be of practical significance for us
living on a nearby planet not all that
different from Mars to understand what
happened I won't go into the the
scientific reasons for going to Mars but
they are manifold but to send a mission
with human crews requires it seems to me
more than scientific justification
because people are much more expensive
between ten and a hundred times more
expensive than some comparable robotic
mission which could do very well in
terms of science and exploration and the
only reason to spend that sort of money
by the way it's it's not huge amount of
money it's tiny fraction of Star Wars
it's in fact in constant dollars less
than the cost of the Apollo program it's
about the cost of a major strategic
weapon system which we seem to have an
endless supply of money to support but
imagine such a mission what could its
political purpose be it can't be
competition with the Soviets in space
that is a issue despite the president's
deep problems in the American space
program we have had enough successes in
space that we don't have to do that but
the idea of the United States and the
Soviet Union together doing an
exploration on behalf of the human
species paving away into the 21st
century capturing the imagination of
people all over the planet that seems to
be something worthwhile a mission which
would for some years be
before the public eye in the
construction of the interplanetary
Transfer Vehicle in Earth orbit in the
voyage to Mars and the sitting down on
the Martian surface Americans and
Soviets together in the exploration of
Mars the some wheeled vehicle for
example down an ancient Martian River
Valley in the return to earth and every
step citizens of these two countries
working together I think it could do
wonders and it uses notice exactly the
same sorts of rocket and nuclear and
computer technology that is also used to
drive the arms race I think there is a
way to use the same technology that has
created some of the very serious
problems we have here on earth
place contaminated with 60,000 nuclear
weapons to undo it by going elsewhere
well I am grateful for the opportunity
to be able to speak to you in honor of
Philip Morrison physicist astronomer
SETI pioneer peerless teacher weapon
year when it counted peace activist when
it counted pasta manufacturer
explorer master of metaphor inspiration
two generations of scientists and others
I should say that in much of this we can
see the wisdom and vitality and
tenderness of Phyllis Morrison who has
clearly played an important part and
fills manifold activities phil has
helped students colleagues and many
readers join the universe but he has
also helped a much vaster audience of
people all over the world many of whom
may never have even heard his name his
kindness his generosity of spirit his
insights his enthusiasm his social
concern have made him a model for other
scientists in the rare art of being a
fully developed human being thank you
[Applause]
other foot
I think we have time for questions
people would like to ask any
yes sir yes
sorry
[Music]
the other Setauket give a couple of days
ago at the National Press Club not on
that issue but I was asked that well
it's it's mixed and it's I guess the
easiest is virtually every newspaper in
America has a daily astrology column how
many of them have even a weekly
astronomy column that's certainly one
one measure but another measure is when
Nobel prizes in science are announced
every year when's the last time you can
recall getting a coherent explanation on
radio or television of what they won
their prizes for it's almost entirely oh
yeah I woke up in the middle of the
night I was surprised I didn't believe
the reporter from Stockholm
my wife was happy
when do we find out what these guys did
to win the Nobel Prize I think that
that's another indication of the state
of journalism another is you look at
people who are called science reporters
for the network's and you find that they
don't report science it's not scientific
ideas theories discoveries it's almost
entirely medicine and technology they
ought to be a medical report it ought to
be a technology reporter but there ought
to be a science reporter I think the
general level of teaching science in the
in the public schools is woefully low
I think scientific attitudes of thought
including skepticism of received wisdom
is desperately needed in various social
economical political and even religious
aspects of our society and isn't there
and this may in fact explain part of the
reason that scientific attitudes of
thought are not taught by and large in
the schools I think this is simply
suicidal I think science ought to be
talked about on some level and over
dinner tables why is it alright for
newspapers to have many many pages of
the fine print on the stock market
really very arcane lots of abbreviations
lots of numbers fractions
why is it alright to have box scores of
baseball games you know with
abbreviations HB RBI no explanation
you're supposed to understand that so
you pick up your daily paper and you
figure well just being a person in the
society I'm expected to know something
about stocks and bonds I'm expected to
know something about baseball and
football I guess I'm not expected to
know anything about science there's not
any of it in here I maintain that
there's an enormous amount of science
that can be taught in in newspapers and
elsewhere that's a whole lot easier than
the stock page and the sports pages yes
please
present status of president status a
nuclear winter well I'm glad to say it's
not here yet
[Applause]
nuclear winter is the contention that if
we are so foolish as to permit a nuclear
war to happen the fine particles of soot
and dust that would be raised would
spread over large land areas would
darken and cool the earth enough to
produce a significant additional peril
for those who survive the direct
consequences of nuclear war and while
there are continuing debates on just how
much the temperature decline would be
and what the duration would be I think
it is fair to say that the consensus of
scientific opinion is that it would be
very serious or maybe the best I can do
is to quote the Department of Defense
which proposes that the consequences of
nuclear winter wouldn't kill perhaps as
many people as the direct consequences
which have been variously estimated for
a central exchange as between a few
hundred million and two billion people
other questions yes please
that's right mr. suppose right now
earnestly have you
human giving future a unified planet
which axis how soon if a miracle
happened in the United States and the
Soviet Union were to agree on what to do
how soon before we could have a unified
world I have a perfect quote from Philip
Morrison prophecy is a lost art
Frances Lowe says especially about the
future
[Applause]
nevertheless I'd like to stress that the
problems that faces were made by people
there is nothing about them that cannot
be unmade by people we have made
extraordinary changes in what we
consider obvious and of course when we
make those changes then we forget but
for example there was a time not so long
ago when the view of the Divine Right of
Kings was widely held worldwide famous
scholars wrote two famous textbooks on
this subject there was a vast vested
political interest to maintain this view
especially among kings
and yet in fact it was even a war fought
here partly on that issue but that view
is not to be found very often today I
mean except for some minor places like I
know Thailand and the United Kingdom
this is this is a view that that is done
or considered chattel slavery the the
view that some people are by right
masters and some people are by right
slaves and that the slaveholders could
do what they wanted was the slaves and
break up families all the rest of that
this doctrine was vigorously supported
by Aristotle it was considered to be an
obvious truth not only that that it was
god-given but that's the way the world
was to be arranged but there's been a
stirring worldwide revolution and there
are very few places on the earth which
chattel slavery is considered acceptable
or permissible or socially respectable
today
well the vested interests in the Divine
Right of Kings and in slavery seem to me
far greater than the vested interests in
continuing the nuclear arms race oh well
there certainly are such vested interest
and everybody on the planet has
something to gain from reversing the
nuclear arms race and I think this is
something that can be done but only if
we understand the nature of the issue
and if we're willing to to take
courageous personal steps to turn the
situation around okay I'm told time only
for one more question please
thank you the questioner says why don't
I make a television program to wake the
world up on these issues I will take it
under advisement
[Applause]